[Music]  tonight I'm going to give someone a  green gown whatever do you mean you know  play nug-nug play a couch quail turn  belly-to-belly is this a riddle drop for  trout in a peculiar River make the Beast  of two backs night psychic night psychic  dance the papian jig prick the master  vein join giblets  I have inflated rubs collaborative pouch  board a long boat in and out make feet  for children stockings do I need to  contact the authorities  no I'm simply going to engage in three  two one and I'm bound to lose I'm going  to pay a bill at sight have a horizontal  refreshment to a bit of business give  someone one give someone what a bit of  that there what are you saying  beard spitting leather stretching naval  engagement hoochie PAP jazz poontang  boils someone's cabbage mattress polo  Ravel up ones little ball of yarn go  like a herd of turtles plate angle toes  palm the pork iris marathon play Night  Baseball ah you mean [ __ ]  [Music]